I unfortunately have to do this segment
there are dangerously delusional people
in my audience
and one of the sorts of segments that
brings it out
is when I report
facts not giving my opinion I give
plenty of opinions on this show I'll say
listen I'm against the death penalty
that's my opinion let me tell you why
and people will write in and they'll say
oh well you know I agree with you or I
disagree or whatever but we know we're
talking about opinion
last week I reported to you that the
rate of inflation was down I didn't say
that we have deflation that's different
I said the rate of inflation is down
a healthy economy expects a little bit
of inflation I've explained why the rate
of inflation is down it wasn't my
opinion these are the numbers and the
numbers have been measured more or less
the same way for decades and I want to
give you some examples of the responses
I saw the comments I saw on YouTube and
you will very quickly see that we have a
tragedy of critical thinking really lack
of critical thinking in this country
Jeff responded quoting me used car
prices have gone down LOL obviously
someone isn't in the used car market
remember this isn't me driving around
looking at used car prices we have
monthly data on this issue folks like
Jeff when the data set used car prices
are up agreed with it because it was
what they wanted to tell as a story
because Joe Biden's president and he's
driving up the prices of used cars even
though it started under Donald Trump
during the pandemic and now it's oh
you're not in the used car market so you
don't actually know what's going on with
used car prices
this isn't my opinion this is the data
if you went to one used car lot and saw
an expensive used car that doesn't mean
anything about what's going on
nationally okay next example from Tulsa
have you checked the math David packman
I bet if you check it you will find that
it's off a lot
I don't know what that means
I am reporting to you the inflation data
we have done stories on what goes into
the inflation number
I'm not doing the math but it's not math
in the sense you think it is this is the
same inflation data that when inflation
was high folks like this pointed doing
that look here are the numbers look at
how high inflation is not an inflation
is coming down they're like oh no the
math is all wrong really what do you
know about the math I'm curious Mr talks
responded LOL I call BS I don't see
prices dropping and eggs are Sky High
eggs aren't cheap so nope now my
personal experience is also that eggs
are expensive right now that's true
uh you know I buy my uh pasture-raised
cage free
liberal hipster eggs and they're
expensive they absolutely are expensive
but I understand that my experience of
buying eggs is anecdotal and it doesn't
tell me what's going on with inflation
numbers nationally but Mr talks saw
expensive eggs so the numbers must be
fake Brian wrote in inflation is down
where nothing has gone down in price
where I live I miss the old David
packman who didn't always simp for the
establishment you might as well work for
CNN or MSNBC you know these comments are
fascinating when I report that gas
prices are up
during Joe Biden's presidency people
like Brian go it's Biden's fault it's
terrible what's going on no questioning
of the data when I report that inflation
is Down based on the same sources Brian
doesn't like the content so it must be
that I'm simping for the establishment I
report data data that has been measured
the same way for decades unemployment
stock market inflation these aren't
opinions folks Zippy wrote in I'm not
seeing it prices are high in
Philadelphia again
you don't understand the difference
between anecdotes
and data
I
how many times do I have to explain this
a Newman with a total what about ISM
where is the coverage on the classified
documents David well I'll tell you where
it isn't in my segment about inflation
the coverage of the classified documents
is in the segment about classified
documents
classic what about ISM and then lastly
Robert says he's this is a different
approach this is the God-fearing
approach
your narrative and lies are catching up
to you God's watching you Parkman
presented completely without comment
this is really scary
because we are here in a country where
the average person lacks a basic degree
of ability to think through a problem
wow the report after inflation being
really high is that inflation is lower I
saw that eggs were expensive is that a
logical way to contradict a report no
it's not but of course that's not the
type of thinking that we frequently see